in the last couple of videos we've seen
that if we have some matrix C that is n
by n it's a square matrix and its
columns columns form an orthonormal set
ortho normal normal set which just means
that the columns are each they've each
been normalized so they each have length
of one if you've you missed column
vectors and they're all mutually
orthogonal to each other so if you
dotted with yourself you get one if you
dot with any of the other columns you
get zero we've seen this multiple times
it's orthogonal to everything else if
you have a matrix like this and I have a
factor you forgot to tell you the name
of this this is called an orthogonal
matrix orthogonal matrix we've already
seen that the transpose of this matrix
is the same thing as the inverse of this
matrix which makes it super SuperDuper
useful to deal with the transpose of
this matrix is equal to the inverse now
this statement leads to some other
interesting things about this so so far
we've been dealing this mainly with the
change of basis I can kind of draw the
diagram that you're probably tired of by
now you know Phi of it'd have some let's
say that's the standard basis let's say
that I have X in coordinates with
another basis we've seen I can multiply
this guy times C to get that up there I
could multiply that guy by C inverse to
get this guy right here and in that
world we viewed C is just a change of
basis we're representing the same matrix
representing the coordinates of how we
represent it but we also know that any
matrix product any matrix vector product
is also a linear transformation so this
change of basis is really just a linear
transformation what I want to show you
in this video and you could view it
easier either as a change of basis or as
a linear transformation is that when you
multiply when you multiply this this
this orthogonal matrix times some vector
it preserves let me write this down it
preserves it preserves lengths lengths
and angles so let's have a little
touchy-feely discussion of what that
means
so let's view it as a transformation
let's say I have some set of vectors in
my domain let's say they look like this
let's say that I'll it looks like this
if let me do it light and I'll draw that
one like that guy and then this guy like
that there's some angle between them and
you know angles are easy to visualize in
r2 r3 maybe a little harder once we get
to higher dimensions but that's the
angle between them now if we preserve if
we if we're saying that we're preserving
the angles and the lengths that means if
I were to multiply these vectors times C
and we can view it as a transformation
maybe I rotate them or I you know you
can't really well maybe I rotate them or
do something like that so maybe that
pink vector will now look like this but
it's going to have the same length this
length is going to be the same thing as
that length and even more when I said it
preserves lengths and angles this yellow
vector is going to look something like
this where the angle is going to be the
same where this theta is going to be
that data that's what I mean by
preserves angles if we didn't have this
case we could imagine a transformation
that doesn't preserve angles
let me draw one that doesn't if this got
transformed to I don't know let's say
this guy got a lot longer and then let's
say this guy also got longer and
actually I want to show that the angle
also doesn't get personality to get
longer but it got distorted a little bit
so the angle also changed this this
transformation right there is not is not
preserving preserving angles so when you
have a change of basis that has a change
of basis matrix that's orthogonal or
when you have a transformation matrix
that's orthogonal all it's essentially
doing to your to your vectors is it can
kind of rotate them around but it's not
going to really distort them so you know
and I'll write that in quotes because
I've never you know it's not a
mathematically rigorous term so no
distortion no distortion of vectors so
I've kind of shown you the intuition of
what that means let's actually prove it
to ourselves that this is the case so
let's say I'm
saying that if I have let's say this
pink vector here is X and that this pink
vector here is C times X I'm claiming
that the length of X is equal to the
length of C times X let's see if that's
actually the case so the length of x
squared or let me do the length of let
me write it this way the length of C x
squared is going to the same thing as C
X dot C X and here it's always useful
for me to kind of remind myself that if
I take two vectors let me do it over
here let's say I have Y dot Y this is
the same thing as Y transpose if you
view them as matrices Y transpose times
y write it let me Y transpose Y is just
you know y1 y2 all the way to Y n times
y 1 y 2 all the way to Y and and if you
were to do this 1 by n times n by 1
matrix product you're going to get a 1
by 1 matrix or just a number that's
going to be Y 1 times y 1 plus y 2 times
y 2 all the way to Y n x y ends this is
the same thing as Y dot Y so let's we I
think I did this 10 or 20 videos ago but
it's always good refresher so let's use
this property right here so these two
dotted with each other this is the same
thing as taking one of their transpose
times the other one so turn this from a
vector vector dot product to a matrix
matrix product so this is the same thing
as CX transpose so you can view this as
a you know it's a 1 by n matrix now
times the n by 1 matrix which is just
the column vector CX these are the same
thing now we also know we also know that
a times B transpose is the same thing as
B transpose a transpose we saw that a
long time ago so this thing right here
is going to be equal to X transpose C
transpose I just switch their order and
take the transpose of each X transpose
times C transpose and then you have that
times
and then you have that x SI X and now we
know that C transpose is the same thing
as C inverse this is what we needed the
orthogonal T this is where we need the
orthogonal T of the matrix C this is
where we need it to be a square matrix
where all of its columns are mutually
orthogonal and they're all normal and so
this thing is just going to become the
identity matrix that's just going to be
identity matrix so you know I could
write the identity matrix there but
that's just going to disappear so this
is going to be equal to X transpose X X
transpose X is the same thing as X dot X
which is the same thing as the length of
x squared so the length of C X squared
is the same thing as the length of x
squared well that tells us that the
length of X or the length of C X is the
length of X right because both of these
are going to be positive quantities so
I've shown you that it definitely that
orthogonal matrices definitely preserve
length let's see if they preserve angles
so we actually had to define angles
because you know we had a you know
brought our mathematical careers we
understood what angles mean in kind of
r2 or r3 but in linear algebra we like
to be general and we defined an angle
using the dot product we use the law of
cosines and we you know took an analogy
to kind of a triangle in r2 but we
defined an angle or we do or we set the
dot product V let me write it this way
I'm sorry this way V dot W it's equal to
it's equal to the lengths of those two
vectors the products of the lengths of
those two vectors times the cosine of
the angle between them or you could say
that the cosine of the angle between two
vectors we defined as the dot product of
those two vectors divided by the lengths
of those two vectors this was a
definition so that we could extend the
idea of an angle to an arbitrarily high
dimension to our our Google if we had to
so what let's see if it preserves so
let's see what the angle is if we
multiply these guys by C so if we want
to you know say our new angle so cosine
of theta see once we perform our
transformation so our new angle well
we're going to perform the
transformation on all of these
characters it's going to be C V dot C W
over the length of C V times the length
of C W now we already know that lengths
are preserved we already know that the
length of C W and C V are just going to
be W and V we just proved that so let me
write that so the cosine of theta C is
equal to C V C W over the lengths of V
times W because we know we already shown
that it preserved length so let's see
what this top part equals so we could
just use the general property the dot
product is equal to the transpose of one
guy as kind of a matrix times the second
guy so this is equal to C W C W
transpose times C V and all of those all
of that over these lengths like the W
and then this is going to be equal to
this is I'm going to write it down here
to have some space we can switch these
guys and take their transpose so it's W
transpose times C transpose times C V
all of that or their lengths the product
of their lengths V and W and this is the
identity matrix that's the identity
matrix so this is going to be equal to W
transpose times V over the products of
their lengths over their products of
their lengths and this is the same thing
as this is the same thing as V dot W
this is V dot W over their lengths over
their lengths which is cosine of theta
which is equal to cosine of theta
so notice by our definition of a of an
angle is the dot product divided by the
vector lengths when you perform a
transformation or if you could imagine a
change of basis either way with an
orthogonal matrix C with an orthogonal
matrix
the angle between the transformed
vectors does not change it's the same as
the angle between the vectors before
they were transformed which is a really
neat thing to know that change of basis
or transformations with orthogonal
matrix matrices don't distort the
vectors they might just kind of rotate
them around or shift them a little bit
but it doesn't change the angles between
them